[Musique]
notre enquête sur les civilisations
disparu est basé sur les très anciens
constructions dont la réalisation est
impossible de correspondre
jusqu'à nos jours ça
ça veut dire dans le passé
l'homme était beaucoup plus évolué et c'est dans
régression
pour le savoir, allons fouiller dans
la nuit du temps
[Musique]
les plus anciennes réalisations attribuées
à la main de l'homme ils remontent jusqu'au dernier
Période paléolithique environ 20 000
il y a des années quand les hommes ont commencé
s'intéresser aux mystères de la vie
après la mort aux amulettes magiques des
chamans et orientations
solsticiels représentés par des mégalithes
[Musique]
ne sont certainement pas ces hommes de
cavernes qui ont construit l'énorme
des bâtiments en pierre qui étonnent
encore nos ingénieurs environ 4 500
il y a des années, ils ont surpris même les hommes
de l'âge du bronze à ces époques
les gens d'Asie Mineure
fondée sur l'île de Crète
la première civilisation européenne la minoenne sur
leur re minos est un essai recommandé
par une caste sacerdotale dont la tâche
est de révéler le passé lointain
ne possédant aucun moyen technique je
les prêtres font confiance aux leurs
expériences mystiques et trouvé
l'ésotérisme un culte du savoir secret
transmis entre initiés
selon ces visionnaires du plus petit
organisme jusqu'à l'ensemble de la nature
tout est conçu comme un être vivant
qui obéit aux mêmes lois
de l'univers appellent donc des dieux
mystérieux
phénomènes impossibles à comprendre avec le
passer du temps à des pratiques ésotériques
connectés aux dieux mystérieux apparaissent
partout dans le monde comme le culte de
Déesse égyptienne des morts
isis à la déesse mère anatolienne cybele al
Le dieu indo-perse est devenu mitre en
suivi un dieu grec et romain et de nombreux
autres divinités
dans la Grèce antique le culte ésotérique
le plus important est celui des mystères de
Eleusis pratiquée dans le temple de Déméter
Je les utilise non loin d'Athènes
culte est consacré aux divinités du
la terre et les enfers
[Musique]
L'ésotérisme grec est aussi pratiqué par
dionysius d'orphée et de pythagore du
mystiques vêtus de blanc et par le régime
nourriture végétarienne quelques siècles
dépenses et autres cultes ésotériques
sont pratiqués dans le monde comme le
cabale du judaïsme et nirvana indien
Tibétain et japonais et soufisme
de l'islam
[Musique]
ainsi parmi les rites oracles, nombres et symboles
visions anges
esprits
éclairage d'alchimie magique et tout
ce qui relève du mystère de la
maîtres spirituels appelés mages
ils transmettent aux disciples un savoir qui
il doit rester caché
[Musique]
au Moyen Âge pendant que Dante écrivait
l'énigmatique comédie divine
les escrocs chantent des poèmes
sur l'alchimie l'oracle le graal e
l'astrologie à la Renaissance
l'ésotérisme est la base de l'hermétisme
Italien de Marsile Ficin dans la Cabale
chrétien de pico della mirandola e
de la théosophie chrétienne de Paracelse
depuis 1600 l'ésotérisme et ses secrets
sont représentés par l'illumination par
rosa cross du néo druidisme de
La franc-maçonnerie franque issue du martinisme mystique
Judéo-chrétien du tarot de
mineurs issus des néo sectes
de l'anthroposophie de rudolf steiner e
du pérenneisme de rené guénon che
suit les traditions initiatiques
authentique
de nos jours l'ésotérisme et
pratiquée par les médecines alternatives depuis
néo catharisme de néo chamanisme de
nouvelle ère de la psychologie transpersonnelle
et de la magie du cosmos qui à travers le
les états de conscience inhibiteurs appellent
tignosi utilise la méditation
la chanson la danse la drogue
douleur et orgasme pour accéder
mystères de la création
[Musique]
après cette présentation partielle
Intéressons-nous à son ésotérisme
enseignements
ap le petit ahurissant selon le
culture ésotérique histoire du monde
commence il y a 400 000 ans avec
l'apparition de grandes civilisations fondées
d'une race humanoïde qui n'était pas un homme
De nombreuses énigmes actuelles sont cachées dans le
différents groupes sanguins e
surtout dans le cerveau humain qui
n'emploie que 10 % des
ses ressources
quand des milliards de réseaux internet pas
suffirait à n'égaler ni le
Puissance
[Musique]
l'adn humain est presque identique à l'adn de
un primate mais intelligent
l'homme surpasse largement
capacité de tout être vivant non
suivant la loi de l'évolution ce
différence entre les primates
l'être humain se pose des questions
sur l'origine de l'homme
[Musique]
les fouilles archéologiques fournissent
la réponse inhabituelle à ces questions
les écrits anciens sur de simples Égyptiens
Juifs, Indiens et le reste du monde
ils disent tous que l'humanité est le
produit d'une manipulation génétique
entre un primate et des êtres venus
depuis l'espace
l'être humain est un farceur on le sait
bien
[Applaudissements]
il y a ceux qui assurent qu'ils ont vu
même visité des soucoupes volantes
sans donner aucune preuve tangible
l'existence des extraterrestres
cependant, nous notons que le plus ancien des livres
Indiens les Védas cite 400 mille races
humanoïdes existant dans la voie lactée
dont une dizaine est déjà venue plusieurs fois
visiter la terre écrit il y a 4000 ans
quand la technologie était à son meilleur
faire fondre le bronze la bada mentionne aussi
d'engins spatiaux équipés de moteurs a
appelés photons de mana qu'ils utilisent
la lumière pour atteindre les planètes quand
leurs orbites se rapprochent
[Musique]
la toute jeune terre fait partie des 100
milliards de planètes qui font partie de
de la voie lactée
mais la vie dans l'espace semble être
apparu beaucoup plus tôt depuis la création
obéir aux mêmes lois partout
autres êtres humains dans l'univers
ils existeraient dans le cosmos et sont plus
homme ancien ainsi de la nuit du
fois
une race humaine vivrait sur plusieurs
planètes et les passagers les plus avancés
ils avaient dans l'espace pour l'explorer
[Musique]
et ce que la tradition ésotérique
dit-il en évoquant une époque ancienne
des milliards d'années quand un souffle
une essence appelée conscience est elle-même
dispersés à travers l'univers animant certains
formes de vie
la conscience a engendré l'espèce humaine
idées d'êtres immortels du pouvoir
mental très développé
[Musique]
dans notre galaxie la voie lactée la
relation avec la conscience et fortement
plein de ressentiment envers les premiers humanoïdes créés e
lorsque ceux-ci acquièrent une
une technologie très avancée est nécessaire
le devoir de rechercher l'espace
d'autres races sœurs dans un but noble
pour les regrouper sous un seul
conscience en se consacrant au partage
la génétique pour que l'un et l'autre viennent
aux facultés des autres
ces humanoïdes forment avec les leurs
comme l'empire cosmique humain dans celui-ci
union interstellaire les composants de
empire se surnomment amis et
ils communiquent par télépathie entre eux
qu'avec tous les autres êtres vivants
leurs gestations se déroulent dans
laboratoire sans rapports sexuels de
appelé la référence à la mère vierge
réfléchir aux actions à mener
les amis descendent dans des chambres profondes
acoustique creusée dans le sol où
utiliser la résonance du son pour
améliorer leur capacité de perception
et entrer en transe
et avec les fréquences audio qu'ils manipulent
la force de gravité
déplacer d'énormes masses de matière e
voyager dans l'espace et dans le temps
puisque la notion de temps est liée
à l'espace que les amis ont
technologies adéquates pour atteindre
passé le présent et le futur
dans de nombreux endroits de la voie lactée
à cette époque la terre avec ses plantes
et ses animaux n'ont pas
importance stratégique
l'homme terrestre n'existe pas chez nous
système solaire et le bord de la rue
voie lactée et l'empire cosmique se positionne
à la base, cependant, un problème se pose
tombe les humanoïdes de l'empire me cherchent
leur aiment les intégrer dans un
seulement la conscience, mais ne remarquez pas que
un autre genre humanoïde à l'envers
aspire à la destruction de l'autre
être vivant
et en partie il réussit parce que ces
les êtres nuisibles infectent génétiquement
quelques amis et ils assimilent les leurs
mauvais gènes
quand l'empire cosmique le découvre
projet destructor déclare à
guerre contre les humanoïdes nuisibles appelés dans
ennemis élimine une bonne partie d'entre eux e
bloque génétiquement la contamination
[Musique]
mais il ne peut pas annuler leurs effets
maintenant infecté forment une nouvelle race
ami hybride à double facette
ennemi mixte des deux rivaux
cependant l'empire cosmique humain ne
oubliez les humanoïdes hybrides
poursuivre son noble dessein
l'unificateur les transfère sur la planète
la terre pour que son positif les ondes
récupérer de l'infection
[Musique]
sur terre les hybrides forment le premier
la civilisation du mou de la lémurie et l'atlantide
mais avec le passage des millénaires au lieu de
guérir leur conscience se dégrade
de plus en plus et ils se retournent contre
l'empire alors cela décide de
les supprimer dévie un gros astéroïde
vers la terre causant un désastre
qui supprime lemuria mou atlantide et moi
leurs habitants
[Musique]
ce bombardement provoque une longue
période d'obscurcissement du ciel
terrestre sans rayons solaires
les forêts gèlent et beaucoup d'animaux font
éteindre
[Musique]
les hybrides sont décimés
mais certains d'entre eux survivent
catastrophe se cachant sous terre e
quand le cataclysme se termine ils sortent et
grâce à leur bagage technologique
ils reprennent leur vie
les survivants des premières civilisations font
puis répartis sur toute la terre e
ils le colonisent en construisant ces ouvrages
colossal qui nous étonne encore pour
la survie de sa propre espèce
cette race humanoïde utilise
la méthode habituelle de traitement
la génétique greffe son propre adn à l'adn
d'un primate et obtient son
descendant terrestre du genre homo de
qui à travers bien des vicissitudes
l'homme sapiens descendra après lui
[Musique]
les religieux
scientifiques et ceux qui suivent
la logique ne crois pas un seul mot de
ce conte de science-fiction le
Physicien et mathématicien français Descartes e
l'adversaire le plus célèbre
le bon sens et la chose
le meilleur que le monde puisse partager
en ce qui concerne les mauvais
doctrines que je pensais déjà connaître
qui sont valables pour ne plus se tromper
ni par les promesses d'un alchimiste ni
des prédictions d'un astrologue ni
des tromperies d'un magicien ni de lui
expédients ou de la vantardise de ceux qui
ils prétendent en savoir plus que
ce qu'ils savent
[Musique]
dans son rationalisme, Descartes soutient
qu'il n'y a aucune preuve tangible que
conte ésotérique est vrai mais il n'est pas là
aucune preuve d'une vérité complètement différente ici
car si la vérité est relative, évitez-la
est la solution la plus adoptée par
scientifiques actuels
[Musique]